the mold may come out cuz we really want
to uplift our black mama's voices so I
want y'all to give it up and let them
feel welcome miss Lorraine and miss
Mildred all right John used to work with
me now okay my name is Lorraine Hank I'm
here representing Coleman advocates and
it is so lovely to see all of you all of
us in one place at the same time is that
beautiful well I just want all the other
know that I am the great-granddaughter
of mr. Scarborough I am the
granddaughter of Johnny mace Tyrell
Tucker I am the daughter of mr. Tucker I
am Lorraine tanks and I stand before you
today to tell you that I stand on the
backs of some strong black women in San
Francisco who paved the way for me and I
just want to fit in in we got Julia
Commons there's a street named after her
we have birth to three men who has a
street named after her
we have Osceola Washington who has a
street named after me
we have Rosa Lee Williams who has the
street met the whole Opera House the
baby Opera House is named after her
Beatriz Dumbo we have a Spinelli Jackson
whose Street is named after her and we
have Eloise Westbrook and when I tell
you guys when you visit the big you
Hunters Point I want all y'all to come
up there and when you see the names
nostris I want you to remember back in
the 60s those streets did not exist
those women that I just named demanded
they demanded that we have housing for
African American people so the thicker
brains thanks you before you the woman
who raised three kids in Bayview at this
point
my brother was gunned down by the police
no justice no peace I cannot sleep do
you hear me I cannot sleep yes we want
the police officers out of the schools
we want to defund the police because
they're making a lot of money off of our
backs our tax dollars pay for the police
[Applause]
[Applause]
we want you to change the system change
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
then we said to our governor it is time
to make change we are sick we are tired
I am tired of walking out my door
wondering if I am going to come back I
am tired of black boys walking out the
doors wondering if they don't come back
it's not fair if you are not going to
lead us to the table they bring us to
the table they give us no water to drink
what are we supposed to do you got black
boys running around these streets yes
they're angry but there's no jobs the
school system won't teach you oh they're
bad we're sending them home they can't
learn nothing at home they can't learn
nothing on these streets and we all know
you learn more only Street in two years
did you do in college and that's sad
that is sad
and I will try to remember one thing
about our kids african-american kids
either die or go to jail and then say
that is sad
we want our children to be able to do
everything that every other kid is
allowed to do all we ask is that you
educate our kids allow them the same
equal opportunities that you give
everybody else and we are creators we
are creators
we are creators and when all these
voices out here we all notes that all of
us are like fish thank you guys again
for coming out we really appreciate the
support
my name is Mildred coffee I am a parent
organizer with Coleman advocates what
we're asking for is to defund the police
out SF USD right now we're asking to
reduce their budget it's use the money
for more safe and supportive schools for
our black children argh like you girls
[Applause]
we also want the funds to go to the
black community organization along with
other communities that will help and
support us to build a network of
restorative justice
[Music]
[Applause]
so we can go beyond quick fixes we're
tired of you telling us our day is
coming we are tired we are tired when
you're telling us we don't have enough
funds for your children to go to school
or do we see the resources that they
need to succeed academically we are
tired the change we need we know it
takes time but we've been here time and
time again the time for change and
students when black families begin to
tell you we're being treated right
that's when you know you're doing
something right but right now we're not
telling you that because it's not
happening for our children it's not
happening for our families we are
citizens here in San Francisco and just
like Lorraine hain't said we've been
fighting forever for housing for jobs
for better schools to educate our
children just stay in our communities to
build our children to be the best that
they can because we know if they are
bright we know that they are smart we're
given the opportunity
get your hands get your knees child up
our necks
our children being express themselves
they're not dogs they are not criminals
they are not people that come out here
just to start becoming negative
something has to happen
that makes them that way and that is
this cruel systemic Weitz's system that
has to be they do not feel safe and they
face teachers and schools who cannot
create the learning environment that
they need because teachers do not
understand their struggle the teachers
that are put before them are young they
don't understand inexperienced we need
experienced qualified and teachers that
have the means to teach our children
don't just come in here given us some
young teacher and she don't know what to
do she's scared for her life so what you
expect a young teacher to do she don't
know what to do so I beg you and I urge
you to take the seat at the table not
just one black people at the table to
change the system into and just seem
like that's the best thing that you can
do we know better
[Music]
right now I'm just shooting and a bit of
a gear mess app so kind of set me back
[Music]
[Music]
it said that we should have we said that
money maybe more money but he didn't say
that joke hoes ought to be a federal
crime so what did the other us to count
I can give him the count of how many
blacks have been killed I can give a
suggestion about chokehold
but when everybody else gives love we
don't want suggestions we want you law
what was done to Kara scratch it was
illegal it was against the law what was
done to Aubree was against the law what
was done to Floyd was against the law
I'm here on Friday
QT last Friday I was preaching the
funeral
of Jorge Flores in Houston Texas why
because it was a funeral that should
have never been here I want them to take
away the memory that people kept
fighting abolitionists black and white
just like black and white a marching now
and they stopped sleeping even when
people got it two and a half years later
justice delayed but they got there so we
can't give up
imagine you still being enslaved two and
a half years after you knew the
proclamation will sign but they didn't
give up why didn't they give up because
they hope if they held on then we would
have a better day and we come to make
sure we do
[Laughter]
hey do you mind if I come down and then
I joined a edit something yeah I already
know al already last I got him yeah I'm
a blood yeah yeah I trade the camera web
he he was out of gonna watch
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we soon love to you wherever you are in
the crowd right now and we send love to
Jobs with Justice cognate executive
director was just here expressing his
support of our demands and the labor
unions and allies that are behind this
fight give it up for library y'all
because that's important to this fight
the city is full of workers that keep
this city going that's important to this
fun so we lift your lamp and we send
your love and we're about to get ready
to march now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but I got some news for you hold on me
let me get my stuff together yes don't
forget to vote that's right okay we
still need everybody to try and social
justice as best as you can
I am trying to be an example to but and
also keep your mouth closed there's more
mass more hand sanitizer over there we
just need my minutes to start this truck
this truck is going to lead our March so
if you are in front of the trip maybe if
you can ship into the street because
we're going to need to um we're gonna
need to start moving this card this trip
we will be positioning where oh I'm
sorry we are going to five five five
Franklin that's our ending destination
but we're gonna make a loop and stop at
the Department of Children Youth &
Families DCYF
but we're going to end at five five five
Franklin Street which is the school
district office y'all hear that make
some noise if you heard that
all right all right all right so we will
be positioning the truck at the front of
the March please give us a few minutes
to just prepare and then we'll give an
announcement when the wreck when the
March is ready to start yes also we want
to stay behind these leading banners
there's an orange banner here also one
that says fun black yield awesome one
that says be fun SFPD so these are our
are leading banners we want to stay
behind those and we want to let this
truck lead us okay so just give us a few
minutes we gonna let a DJ lucky spin Sam
and we go Marsha hello my name is yeah
that first name is spelled n like Nancy
K e CH hi last name is nuber and you the
e RG oh well I actually I'm an artist
I'm also minister we're going to church
and oh yeah tell me why you decided to
come out here today well my goodness how
could I not
let me just I'm just gonna sorry I just
need to queue this up right here if I I
was in the middle of something let me
just get that going I mean apart from
just the the very clear fact that black
lives matter apart from the very clear
fact that our United States was built on
a foundation of black oppression it is
it's really sad I actually am partly
from Nigeria so I grew up overseas and
coming to America and over time slowly
becoming aware of the actual compression
that is just embedded into people's
souls and that they continue to carry
out I I'm aghast at the fact that we
were able to watch George boy's life
leave him and have people even wonder
what he did and that just was so sad so
I am just all for us starting today
ending the violence now it's not
necessary you know growing up in a
country where where you know there was a
military rule I don't know how we got
into that mode but it's wrong and I'm
just really in support of everything
that I can be to help move us forward
and become the United States of America
that we purport to be we say that we're
free we say that we're America you know
everybody communicates this great
message and so we just need to take it
all the way and have that message
actually be true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you